on en trouve encore des quantités de nos
jours des shadoks prisonnier de ce temps
là malheureusement on ne les voit pas
mais sont la transformer en arbre en
cailloux ou objets ménagers apparemment
innocent apparemment seulement parce que
méfiez vous c'est shadoks là ont gardé
au plus profond de leur coeur une soif
de vengeance qui ne s'était rétracté
mais maintenant ils n'ont pu 2 et gêne
évidemment ou de gy be sure qui se
venger mais ça ne fait rien parce que
tout ce qui bouge maintenant sur la
terre pour eux c'est du jet de celle qui
vous tombe sur la tête exprès parce que
vous passez dessous vous pouvez être sûr
que c'est une échelle sadok le canot qui
dépasse le bec de gascon n'a pas vu tout
ça aussi c'est les shadoks
et quand vous roulez en auto à une
allure normale et que tout d'un coup
sans prévenir à platanes la route c'est
pas par hasard c'est un platane chat
doctrine a fait exprès